[Music]
foreign
welcome back so this is the third
lecture on the series of eigenvalues
eigenvectors and how to solve systems of
differential equations this is one of my
absolute favorites because this is where
it all comes together so I'm staying
late just for this lecture in the last
few we have talked about why we have you
know these ordinary these systems of
ordinary differential equations x dot
equals ax X is a vector a is a matrix
and these Dynamics are coupled but it's
a lot easier to solve this system of
equations if a was a diagonal matrix so
we try to find a coordinate
transformation some Matrix T some
invertible Matrix T into some new
coordinate system Z so that Z dot equals
a diagonal matrix Z because this is way
way easier to solve this system where D
is diagonal and the Dynamics are
decoupled then this system here where a
is not diagonal and specifically we
derived the eigenvalue eigenvector
equation for the t's and the D's where
this is possible specifically
a times T equals T times D this is the
eigenvalue problem Columns of T are
eigenvectors of a the diagonal elements
of D are eigenvalues of a so so the the
coordinate transformation that
diagonalizes a are specifically The
Matrix of eigenvectors of a and the D
the diagonal system that you get after
doing that these diagonal entries of D
are the eigenvalues of a good so I think
I want to just show a couple of things
I'm going to do a little bit of python
Matlab demonstration here just to
convince you that yes in fact d
equals what did I have t inverse a t is
true and also conversely that if I had D
and T
um
that a would equal
uh
T times d
times T inverse okay and it's really
really really easy to compute
eigenvalues and eigenvectors in Matlab
and python so I'm just going to show you
that real quick and then what I'm going
to do kind of the culmination of this
set of lectures is I'm going to use I'm
going to assume that we've gotten a
we've decomposed a into its eigenvectors
T and its eigenvalues D so you know
however means you know python or Matlab
we started with a and we solved for T
and d and then I'm going to show you
that with those matrices I can solve my
original system of equations up here so
this is like my favorite lecture in
differential equations so far and so I'm
just going to show you right now
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm literally just going to
confirm in fact that you know it's easy
to get eigenvalues and eigenvectors okay
so I'm going to start in Matlab so I'm
creating an a matrix 0 1 negative 2
negative 3 and all I'm going to do is
get its eigenvectors T and its
eigenvalues D using the IG command the
built-in IG command so it's literally
one line to get all of the eigenvectors
and all of the eigenvalues so I'm just
going to uh run that
and so T our eigenvectors one okay so it
normalizes them so that they have length
one so if you take you know this entry
squared plus this entry squared it'll
have length one same with this but
um essentially you can think of this as
you know the one negative One Direction
and this is the I guess it looks like
the minus one two direction
and what I'm going to confirm for you
and then our eigenvalues are negative
one and negative two
so I'm going to confirm these two
expressions here
so if I take
in of T times a times T that had better
equal my diagonal matrix
and yes in fact it does minus one zero
zero minus two and I'll confirm the
other one that if I take T times my
diagonal matrix times the inv of T that
should equal my original a matrix and in
fact it equals 0 1 minus 2 minus 3. good
quick sanity check it's real easy to get
eigenvalues and eigenvectors one line of
Matlab and these properties that we
think should hold do in fact hold
let's just do kind of similar things in
in Python here again you can you know
import numpy as NP I actually don't need
these other ones this is just from
another script so I'm going to create an
array the same array 0 1 minus two minus
3 and it's just as easy to get
eigenvalues and eigenvectors it's just
you know from NP Lin alge it's again the
IG command so just I give a and it spits
out eigenvalues and eigenvectors in
these these structures so I'll just run
this run run edit printed out the
eigenvalues if I want to uh what's
happening
if I want to print the E the IG Vex that
should also work and again it is
normalizing them to be unit
um unit Norm so you can Define your
eigenvector any Vector along an
eigenvector direction is technically an
eigenvector we usually pick the
convention that our eigenvector has a
unit length that uniquely determines it
okay and these are the same as before
and so clearly these are also going to
hold
good um that's all I wanted to show you
in code so now what I'm going to do
is we are going to use these um diagonal
matrix D and these eigenvectors T to
solve our differential equation
okay
um and so we know
that it's quite easy to compute
um it's easy to compute the solution of
this this is just
um
Z of T equals e to the Matrix D time
times whatever initial conditions I have
I should probably write down my initial
conditions I have you know X at time 0
are my initial conditions and those
initial conditions are going to you know
have a corresponding initial condition
in Z this is literally
Z naught is T inverse X naught that's
pretty simple
and I'm
mentions x dot equal s Lambda X if I had
um if I had x dot equals Lambda X for a
scalar X and for a number Lambda
and I had some initial condition
then the solution would be X at time T
equals e to the Lambda t
times my initial condition e to the
Lambda T times x naught and so here I'm
guessing
that I get something similar that X my
Vector X at time T is probably going to
be e to the Matrix a
times time
the vector of initial conditions okay
now the question is how do I compute
this Matrix exponential I haven't shown
you how to do this and so that's kind of
one of the things I'm going to show you
in this lecture is how do you compute
this Matrix exponential and how do you
use T
and D to make it really easy to compute
this thing
okay
um
so
I shouldn't have erased all of my stuff
so we know that a
is equal to
t d
T inverse
what do I want to to do here I want to
tell you that this Matrix exponential
sorry I'm skipping a step here this
Matrix exponential e to the A
T and I'm going to drop the under bars
we know that a is a matrix
I told you before that you can take the
power series expansion for the
exponential e to the X and you can
substitute in this Matrix a t every time
you see that variable X so the power
series expansion of exponential says
that this should be
um
I'll write e to the X so e to the x is
just 1 plus X Plus x squared over 2
factorial plus X cubed over three
factorial plus x to the fourth over four
factorial plus Dot
and so this
this is going to be a matrix this isn't
going to be a scalar so instead of one
it's going to be the identity
and instead of X it's going to be I'm
going to substitute in a t every time I
see an X so plus a t plus a squared t
squared over 2 factorial plus a cubed T
cubed over three factorial plus dot dot
dot dot forever and ever and ever
now
Computing these Matrix Powers is going
to get pretty tedious pretty fast like
matrix multiplication is not cheap for
big matrices so I don't want to be
actually Computing all of these Matrix
powers and so I'm going to use T and d
and special properties of those to make
it really really easy to compute these
things that's that's kind of uh what I'm
going to show you now
Okay so um
we already know that a equals T DT
inverse that's fine we computed this
using you know the IG command and python
or Matlab and now I can write that a
squared this is where it gets pretty fun
a squared is just this thing times
itself so it's t d
T inverse
times t d
T inverse
but notice that I have a t inverse times
T so these actually cancel out
and this equals
T times my diagonal matrix squared
times T inverse
and this is actually not so bad to
compute D Squared is easy I just Square
all of the diagonal entries right like a
diagonal matrix times itself a diagonal
matrix squared is just the square of the
diagonal entries okay it's another
diagonal matrix where the entries are
squared so this is actually easier to
compute similarly we can compute A3
a cubed that is uh t d t inverse times t
d t inverse times T I hope you're seeing
the pattern here T inverse
again all of these in the middle cancel
and I'm left with
t
D to the third power
T inverse again this is really easy to
compute D cubed that's just a diagonal
matrix with all of the entries of D
cubed so that's nice and I can do this
add nauseum if I wanted
um
dot dot dot
a to the power n the nth power of a is
just going to be the same exact thing
it's going to be t
D to the power n
times T inverse
and so basically every single term in
here whenever I see an A or an a squared
or an A cubed or so on and so forth I
can plug in these expressions in terms
of its eigen decomposition in terms of
its eigenvectors and eigenvalues
sometimes I call that it's eigen
decomposition this is the eigen
decomposition of a
and I'm going to use one more fact which
is that this identity
I
can be written as t
times T inverse okay that's all we need
to write this down
so what I'm going to write is that this
expression here equals maybe I'll use
pink since most of these here are pink
so this equals uh
T times T inverse
Plus
T times D times T inverse little time
plus T times D squared times T inverse
little times squared over 2 factorial
Plus
T times D cubed T inverse little time
cubed over 3 factorial plus dot dot dot
forever and ever and ever
and now what I can do is I can say that
every single term in this has a big T on
the left
and a big T inverse on the right this
scalar thing I can move that anywhere
because it's just a scalar so the Matrix
part of this has a big T on the left and
a t inverse on the right for every
single term in this expansion
and so that equals Big T
times identity
plus dot a bunch of stuff
times T inverse and this is the stuff
inside is the identity plus a diagonal
matrix t plus a diagonal matrix squared
t squared over 2 factorial plus a
diagonal matrix cubed T cubed over three
factorial Plus
and now you'll see so like if that was
too fast just pause and convince
yourself that this equals this I
literally just popped this big T on the
left from all of these and this big T
inverse on the right from all of these
and then I collected all the stuff in
the middle identity Big D times T Big D
Squared t squared over two factorial D
cubed T cubed over three factorial
and now
actually really really easy all of the
stuff in the middle is the power series
expansion the the representation of e to
the diagonal matrix t
but we know that this is actually really
easy to compute all of these matrices
all of these powers of D are just
still diagonal matrices and so to get
this e to the power Matrix D times t
this is literally just a diagonal matrix
you know e to the Lambda 1 t e to the
Lambda 2T dot dot dot dot with zeros
everywhere else I can just write this
Matrix exponential down for this
diagonal matrix I don't even have to
compute this this is just I can write
this down okay it's a diagonal matrix
with e to the Lambda T's
and so now I hope you're seeing that
instead of computing this infinite set
of powers of a which is going to be
heinous to do now all I have to do is
compute the eigen decomposition I get T
and D
I compute e to the DT and I multiply it
on the left with Big T and on the right
with Big T inverse and that is my
solution my solution X at time T I'm
going to write this down maybe I'll
write it down in green
X at time t
is equal to Big T
e
to the diagonal matrix times time
times Big T inverse that's e to the a t
all of this is e to the a t
times
X naught
okay this is the solution this is
the solution
to x dot equals a x
with this initial condition X naught
original differential equation that was
really hard to solve maybe I could have
you know guessed that this is the form
of the solution but still how do I
compute this Matrix exponential this is
going to be a nightmare to do for a
generic a matrix so instead what we do
is we think well it would be a lot
easier if this was diagonal so let's
find a coordinate transformation into a
coordinate system Z where my Dynamics
are diagonal
and decoupled so I know how to solve
that easily it's easy to compute e to
the
diagonal matrix T I do that by finding
my eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this
a matrix so my eigenvectors T my
eigenvalue is D and then I also find
that those eigenvalues and eigenvectors
make it much much easier for me to
compute this Matrix exponential I can
kind of write every time I see an a
matrix I can write it in terms of its
eigenvalues and eigenvectors I can split
terms and collect terms and get this
very simple expression that that Matrix
exponential e to the Matrix a times time
is a matrix I know times a really easy
diagonal exponential Matrix times
another Matrix I know I can compute all
three of these terms very very easily
whereas I could not compute all of these
infinitely many terms easily so this is
much much nicer
okay one last thing I want to show you
this is kind of uh for me one of the
highlights of this lecture is now we're
going to interpret this expression this
solution so this is a big deal this is
the solution we're going to interpret
this step by step okay
so this T inverse times x naught
T inverse times x naught is literally Z
naught so this term here is
Z naught
so essentially what we're doing is we
are taking our initial conditions in the
x coordinate system in my original
coordinate system that I you know I
wrote down my Dynamics in my original x
coordinate system for some reason I must
have had a good reason so now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take my
initial conditions
I'm going to map them through T inverse
into a set of initial conditions in my
nice Z coordinate system so this is you
know I'm writing I'm writing
my initial conditions
uh in Z coordinates in Z coordinates
then what I'm doing
is I'm multiplying by e to the Matrix d
t so this whole thing e to the Matrix
the diagonal matrix D times time times Z
naught
this is literally
Z at some future time T this is z of t
so what I've done is I've taken my
initial condition I've mapped it into Z
coordinates where it's easy to to write
down the solution it's easy to write
down Z of T in these Z coordinates it's
just you know my initial condition times
this diagonal matrix that's Z of t
so this is my uh solution
in Z coordinates
which is easy
and then finally what I do is now I have
the solution in Z coordinates but again
I wanted it in x coordinates in the
first place I care I started in x
coordinates and so to get back to x
coordinates I just multiply by a big T
that's multiplied by Big T and now I'm
back in X so now we're back to the
solution
in x
coordinates and I think this is just
really really cool like this for me is
one of my favorite pictures in uh in
differential equations is
um
this solution here and this real
physical interpretation these matrices T
and D are not magic okay this is not uh
eigenvalues and eigenvectors don't come
out of nowhere they are very very simple
and intuitive matrices that are useful
for solving systems of differential
equations the T inverse Matrix Maps me
from x coordinates into Z coordinates my
initial condition X naught into Z naught
in those Z coordinates my Dynamics are
diagonal this diagonal matrix are my
eigenvalues of my a matrix and so it's
easy to write e to the DT to solve to
move Z naught forward in time to Z at
some future time
and then to go back to my original
coordinates I just multiply by T again
so very very intuitive very very kind of
simple in terms of eigenvectors and
eigenvalues how you solve x of t Okay
um good that was it that was a big
lecture I'm ready to go home now
in the next lectures we're going to look
at specific a matrices that have certain
structure that have really interesting
eigenvalues and eigenvectors so for
example when these eigenvectors are
purely real and negative this will be a
stable system when they're purely real
and positive it'll be an unstable system
when they are imaginary I'll have a
rotating system you know kind of
oscillating system cosines and Sines and
I'm going to build up all of your
intuition for these systems of
differential equations for the whole
menagerie of of ordinary differential
equations you can have in terms of these
eigenvalues and eigenvectors this is the
new language we're going to use to
understand these systems of equations
okay that's all coming up soon thank you
[Music]